hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll this is the
Q&A video associated with the idea of
geometry and topology two ideas I know I
understand but we're gonna get pretty
straightforwardly into this Q&A video
it's gonna be a combination as usual of
questions people actually asked and
things that I kind of would have liked
to say and I'm gonna use this excuse to
say them the first one I'm gonna start
with is the idea of embedding so we
talked just to remember in the geometry
and topology video about come on now we
talked about two things the geometry
section was about how you intrinsically
define the geometry of some space some
space we call a manifold okay a manifold
is the kind of thing you can define the
geometry of and the insight of Gauss and
Riemann that need to do that the two
interesting things number one you could
do it locally so you could have
curvature of some kind of space that
could change from point to point it
didn't have to be like a plane or a
sphere where the curvature was that's
exactly the same at every point you
could actually characterize locally what
the curvature is and number two you
could make that characterization without
thinking about the embedding of the
manifold we're talking about in some
bigger space so that raises the question
of what do you mean by an embedding of
something okay so let's get the idea
straight first and then we'll define it
a little bit more carefully a little bit
more mathematically just think about the
circle s1 the one dimensional sphere it
can be embedded in the plane r2 oops I
could write a better two than that so we
mean by that is of course we can have
X&Y
okay so we have our coordinates on the
plane r2 and let's say we have a circle
of radius capital R centered on the
origin okay so we can draw a circle
let's see if I can actually make that
happen
and try to Center it in the middle more
or less there we go and we're gonna say
that the radius of this circle is
Capital are okay so when we sort of this
is how math works very often that we
have some idea and we try to make sense
of it it's very much like physics except
we're never comparing our ideas to data
we're just comparing them to other ideas
that's why it's a little bit more
abstract sometimes than physics is so in
this case you can say well look I have
the plane I can just draw on the plane
right there on the board and I can draw
the circle inside and it's kind of
obvious what I mean
we want to translate that into equations
that we can manipulate it you know again
this this goes back when we talked about
space in one of the videos a long time
ago and you talk about extra dimensions
of space and or when you talk about
Hilbert space in quantum mechanics and
the number of dimensions of Hilbert
space can be enormous ly large and we
could have extra dimensions of ordinary
space that are hidden from our view and
people want to say well how do you
visualize it right and the answer is you
can try and there's sort of shortcuts to
doing your job but ultimately it doesn't
matter how you can visualize it or not
what you need is a rigorous mathematical
description so that you don't need to be
able to visualize it anymore and this is
exactly that kind of thing that we're
doing here we had this visualization of
drawing a circle in a plane we want to
promote that to some careful
mathematical characterization and then
once we have that we can talk about
embedding an eight dimensional circle in
a twenty men tional space completely
impossible to visualize but the
equations will guide us so one way of
thinking about the circle embedded in
the plane is well we have coordinates on
the plane okay and so we can say where
the circle is as a subset of the plane
by specifying the sum condition on the
coordinates so the circle in this case
is x squared plus y squared equals R
squared in other words the circle is a
subset of the plane consisting of all of
the ordered pairs X comma Y such that
this is true in other words to be a
little bit more formal s1 equals the set
of ordered pairs X Y such that x squared
plus y squared
equals R squared at least this circle
equals that there's other circles you
can put elsewhere and of course if we're
only interested in the topology rather
than the geometry we can also smush the
circle in different ways but now this is
just a particular circle we would like
to care about so this might lead you to
believe and be perfectly natural to say
well the right way of thinking of an
embedding of one space in a bigger space
is to start with the bigger space and
find a subset of it maybe of some
different dimensionality it turns out
that in general that's not the most
useful way to do it in particular if we
want to do the geometry inside the
embedded space so inside the circle we
haven't put any coordinates on the
circle itself here right we just had the
coordinates in the plane we're sort of
really taking advantage of the fact that
we're living in the plane and the spirit
of geometry of Riemannian geometry is
that we shouldn't care about the space
we're embedded in we should care about
the space that we're intrinsic to that
we're living in so one thing we can do
is is put coordinates on the circle by
defining an angle theta
okay so theta goes from 0 to 2 pi let me
let me be very careful about it and
write it this way this is this square
bracket means that we include 0 in our
coordinates and the round parentheses
means we don't include 2 pi so every
number less than 2 pi and greater than
or equal to zero is included here so
theta equals zero is this point right
here this is theta equals PI over 2 this
is theta equals PI this is theta equals
three-halves pi and this is almost 2 pi
ok and 0 so now we know where we are in
the circle in terms of theta and we can
relate theta to x and y and in fact we
can do that so this is really how a
modern mathematician would think of an
embedding from s 1 into R 2 as a map
remember math additions are constantly
thinking of maps between different
spaces so we have the circle by itself
with coordinates between 0 and 2 pi we
have R 2 by itself with coordinates X
and
and what we want is a map so whenever
you give me a value of theta I give you
a value of X and a value of y so if you
think about it I want something that
says that x equals R when theta equals 0
and then X goes to 0 as theta goes to PI
over 2 X goes to what minus 1 when theta
goes to PI etc so if you think about it
what does that do we plotted theta and
we plot X what is X doing and let's put
tick marks here for this is 2 pi so this
is pi PI over 2 and 3 PI over 2
ok so we're looking for is a curve that
is equal to 1 at the beginning goes down
to 0 then minus 1 then 0 again then up
to 1 again when we go all the way around
the 2 pi so it looks like this and now
if this isn't immediately recognizable
to you this is the cosine of theta and
sorry I said x equals 1 but in fact what
I want is x equals R okay
when theta equals 0 so this is this
curve is R cosine theta whereas Y starts
out at zero right y equals 0 when X
equal 1 theta equals 0 it goes up to
capital R then it goes back down to 0
then it goes to minus R then it goes
back to 0 so Y goes like this and again
that's a very famous curve this is R
times sine of theta so what we have is
an explicit map between the coordinates
where X sorry all the way around
theta which is a single point on the
circle goes to a point in R to the
ordered pair R cosine theta comma R sine
theta so that's an example of an
embedding and embedding is a map from
the small space the space being embedded
into the bigger space the space in which
its embedded and then once you get that
idea you can do that not just
a circle but you could do it for two
spheres the whole thing that you know
just you find some coordinates on the
small space and you map those
coordinates into the bigger core the
coordinates of the bigger space that's
what embedding is so that's what an
embedding is we would have put it to
work we want to understand because
someone asked how do you get the metric
for a space where you don't know what
the embedding is in some bigger space
and you know the answer is you just do
that's sort of what it is but I get why
there's a question there because very
often it can be useful to actually
define a space in terms of its embedding
like very often people say what do you
mean by a circle there's a topological
way of talking about the circle
intrinsically but you could also say the
circle is the set of all points in the
plane a distance R from the origin
distance capital R that is fixed right
that defines a circle so you might think
well the definition of some space is how
it's embedded in a bigger space and then
you can inherit the metric on the
smaller space from the metric on the
bigger space so let's see how that
actually works so consider a sphere two
dimensional sphere s to the two
dimensional surface of a sphere the
conventional thing embedded in r3 okay
embedded in three dimensional space and
this is very helpful because we know a
lot we have some intuition about our
three here's X Y Z and we can imagine a
sphere embedded in this space okay and
here's a sphere make it a bit bigger
maybe yeah there we go
okay good so this is yes I want to move
it there we go so this is a sphere and
so it has an equator okay and I'm gonna
pick out a point on the sphere there we
go and let's say again radius R for our
sphere and again the whole thing is x
squared plus y squared plus Z squared
equals R squared that is one way of
talking about the definition of this
sphere I want to put coordinates now on
the sphere how do I do that well now
we're gonna what we're gonna do is drop
down a line into the XY plane from
whatever point we started at we're gonna
go
vertically down in the z-direction till
we hit the XY plane and that's going to
define for us this angle between the
x-axis and where we get to and we're
going to call that fine okay
then we're also going to define an angle
that starts at the z axis in the minus
direction so we're gonna draw let's say
a line of longitude here that goes
through our point goes all the way to
the South Pole and then the angle from
the South Pole up here we're gonna call
theta so we have two angles that we can
define to tell you where you are on the
sphere Phi goes from 0 to 2 pi because
if you think about it as you go around
the circle you can go anywhere around
the equator so Phi goes from 0 to 2 pi
just to make it a little bit simpler
here let me just redraw this Phi is this
way theta is this way okay
that's the secret that's it that's
that's what the coordinates are on the
sphere so theta goes from 0 to PI if you
think about it because inclusive because
0 is the angle at the South Pole pi is
the angle at the North Pole measured in
radians and you don't need to keep going
because you've already covered the other
half of the sphere with just for the
different value of Phi ok so they have
different ranges but these ranges all
told cover the whole sphere you will
also notice I was trying to be careful
here Phi goes from 0 inclusive to 2 pi
exclusive because 0 and 2 pi are the
same theta needs to go from 0 to pi
including both because theta equals 0 is
the point namely the South Pole faith
equals PI is the point the North Pole
okay and so what that means is for any
value of Phi when theta equals 0 you're
at the South Pole so there's a sort of
not quite smooth map it's not an
invertible map from theta and Phi to the
South Pole but who cares and you know
you know how to do it anyway and the
point of me telling you this is that if
you know the metric in three-dimensional
flat space which you do
it's flat then you can figure out what
the metric on the sphere is supposed to
be so let me explain what I mean by that
so the metric in three-dimensional space
I mean you can have whatever metric you
want but there is a conventional metric
we often use which is the flat one again
if this is X Y Z and I have some length
I mean let's imagine the length is very
short so it's D s is the infinitesimal
length there okay well then I can again
drop this down and figure out that there
is a component in the X direction the X
component in the Y Direction D Y
component the Z Direction going this way
DZ and then the length DS just obeys
Pythagoras's theorem generalize to three
dimensions instead of two dimensions D s
squared is DX squared plus dy squared
plus DZ squared okay that should be
believable enough and what I claim is
that I'm not going to do it it's a
little bit of trigonometry involved here
but if you know how to do this embedding
from the two sphere into
three-dimensional space in terms of the
cosines and sines in other words you
know the one higher dimensional version
of this which is easy enough to do then
you can actually plug that in to this
equation for the metric and this is the
metric in r3 and you can derive from
that a metric just on the sphere DS
squared on the sphere and what it will
end up looking like is R squared D theta
squared plus R squared sine squared
theta D Phi Square and that's not
suppose to be obvious not so stable to
guess that okay this is the right answer
this is the metric on what we call the
round to sphere in math we call it that
because two spheres often just meant any
topological sphere which we can smush if
we want and so calling it the round two
sphere means a sphere we have not
smushed a sphere that is actually
completely geometrically smooth and
uniformed and I'm not going to derive
this you can drive it at home if you
want to but I will try to justify it a
little bit think again
once again about
our sphere actually forget about these
axes who cares about Euclidean space in
which we're embedding it in we don't
need that anymore
just take the sphere okay here's our
sphere and we're gonna have I don't want
to make it bigger good they have the
equator and then we're gonna let's say
here is our I guess we need this one so
here is the x-axis okay that's the one
axis we're gonna need yeah we're gonna
need two z-axis also that's X and Z and
then we have some point on the sphere
okay that has coordinates theta and Phi
as before what we're gonna say is let's
imagine we have a small distance along
the sphere between two points label that
D s that's the length of that small
little line interval on the sphere and
we want to express it in terms of the
dist the the changes of theta and Phi so
we want to do is zoom in on that so
let's take this picture move it to the
side so we can keep it for comparison
purposes okay we're gonna zoom in on
that little thing on the sphere so we
have two points of length D s what we're
gonna do is just as before we're gonna
sort of draw a line of longitude
longitude through the first point and
then we have a line of latitude oops
supposed to be through the first point
sorry about that let me erase this but
this up here Z is up there no line of
latitude very very good so we're
comparing the second point to the first
point so this little segment here has a
coordinate change D theta this little
segment has a coordinate change D Phi
but here's what you notice the metric of
course the metric is going to be
proportional to R squared because the
metric is the distance squared and as
you change the radius of the sphere all
the distances change with R so the
distance squared changes with R squared
so of course there's going to be an R
squared and as theta changes remember
theta is the angle up this way
theta is unit
form on the sphere a change in theta
leads to the same physical change in
distance no matter where you are on the
sphere so it's not surprising to see D
theta square
but in Phi that's not the same in Phi if
you're here at the equator D Phi being
any size leads to a large change in
physical distance whereas up here near
the pole the same change in Phi the same
change in which line of longitude you're
on change is only a small physical
distance okay so what we want is to take
our squared D Phi squared but multiplied
by some function which is small when
theta equals 0 grows to 1 when theta
equals PI over 2 and then grows back
down to 0 and theta equals PI because
that's the range of theta ok so theta is
telling us which line of latitude
we're on so let's see if we can find a
function like that oh yes we can if you
look at the green line right here the
sine function goes from 0 at theta
equals 0 to 1 at theta equals PI over 2
and then down to 0 again so that's
reflecting the fact that a circle is
small at theta close to 0 is big a line
of latitude is big at theta equals PI
over 2 and then it's small again at
theta equals PI so that's why we get R
squared sine squared theta D Phi squared
so even though I didn't derive it I
think that it makes some physical sense
why the metric the formula for the
distance squared an infinitesimal
distance squared in terms of the
coordinate changes has this particular
form the point is I can literally derive
it by starting with this starting with
the formula for the Euclidean
three-dimensional thing plugging in the
formulas for what XY and Z equal as
functions of theta and Phi doing a bit
of calculus and this would pop out if
you're familiar with that then it's very
natural to ask well what if I don't have
any of that what if I if you're telling
me like space-time the four-dimensional
space-time in which we live
isn't embedded in some bigger space then
how do I know what the metric is okay
this I have a very short answer to this
I'm giving this long-winded explanation
just so you know a little bit more about
embeddings but the short answer is the
you don't know ahead of time what the
metric is that's what you're solving for
when you're doing something like a
general relativity okay in general
relativity the game you play as you say
at some physical situation you have
let's say I have matter distributed
uniformly through space but it's allowed
to expand or contract and then you ask
what is the metric corresponding to that
situation and so you try to find a
formula for the infinitesimal distance
as a function of T time x y&z okay and
that will be your metric that can
describe that physical situation you go
back and forth you know you're doing
science now you're not doing math you're
asking what kind of metric what
functional form of the metric as a
function of XYZ and T can possibly
describe this physical situation and
never during that operation do you need
to actually talk about any embedding
space outside so when we get to talk
about general relativity we will see
that procedure in action a little bit
okay another question totally separate
question remember we talked about the
Riemann tensor and I want to talk just a
little bit about different ways of
thinking about the Riemann tensor I told
you a way of talking about it which is
not the way that almost anyone would
talk to you about it when they initially
proposed it when they initially
explained it to you so what I said was
look let's say you have some vector v1
another vector v2 and you use that to
define a little loop a little closed
loop in space by they're both
infinitesimal vectors so you sort of
infinitesimally follow first down v1
then v2 then backward along v1 again and
then backward along v2 and while you're
doing that you take a third vector call
it v3 and it gets moved around by
parallel transport so knowing what the
connection is on whatever manifold you
have that's a rule for what the
components of the vector do as you
parallel transport them so you're going
to go around a
okay you're gonna go around a loop and
let's say clockwise direction this way
and you're gonna find at the end that if
space is flat the definition of flat in
this case is that v3 comes back to
exactly where it started no matter what
v2 and v1 were and in fact no matter
what v3 is any vector transform around
any loop comes back to where it started
that means space is flat at least at
that point but in general it won't okay
so the v3 will change from here to here
and so we are able to define another
vector v4
so the Riemann tensor literally is a map
from three vectors v1 v2 v3 oops - yeah
from three vectors to a fourth vector
the fourth okay it's an answer to the
question given the vector v1 v2 I go
around the loop carrying with me vector
v3 by what does vector v3 change the
answer is vector V 4 that's what the
Riemann tensor tells you okay
but there's a little abstract even
though it's very physical way of sort of
drawing the picture etc we need to be
able to put it to you so once again we
need a way of sort of quantifying it a
way of actually taking the answer to the
question by what vector does it change
and making it coherent making it making
it specific giving you actual numbers or
formulas or whatever and the way we
usually do that is coordinates okay so
we pick not just random vectors v1 and
v2 but we say like on our curved
manifold whatever it is there's some
coordinates I'm going to draw them as
squiggly lines just so they're not
necessarily Cartesian or polar or
whatever but they're just some
coordinates and call them maybe X is
increasing in this direction Y is
increasing in that direction okay and so
at any one point let's take this point
right here I can say well I move a
little bit in X and that defines a
vector in the X direction and then I
move a little bit in Y that defines a
vector in the Y direction
okay and it's perfectly clear what those
vectors are like they're along these
coordinate labels these lines okay so
having coordinates defines vectors
automatically and therefore all these
vectors v1 v2 v3 rather than just saying
give me any vector I can say give me the
specific vectors at every one point that
point along the directions of my
coordinate lines and if I answer the
question about the Riemann tensor for
those vectors those vectors are a basis
it's a vector space I can express any
vectors as a sum of the vectors as a
weighted sum of the vectors here and
that's therefore all I need to do so in
so typically people will give you the
Riemann tensor by saying well I'm gonna
move along so let's do it this way let's
let X mu be the set of coordinates and
let's say the set of all coordinates let
me just write very vaguely coordinates
so specifically in space that would be
XYZ maybe or maybe X R theta sorry R
Theta Phi if we were doing polar
coordinates in space time this could be
T for time XYZ okay or something like
that doesn't matter whatever the
coordinates are on your manifold and
then there's a vector pointing in the
direction of each coordinate and so then
R I can think of the Riemann tensor R as
being specified by a set of numbers
namely the coordinates of the vectors in
this coordinate system so what I need is
R equals a set of numbers
well I won't write R because R will mean
something else in another video soon
enough so let me say Riemann tensor
so this is not Riemann tensor at all
this is just coordinates Riemann tensor
is a set of numbers equal to what the
components of these vectors are in this
coordinate system or in other words if
you give me if you do give me V 1 V 2 V
3 this set of numbers converts it into V
4 ok in coordinates X mu and what that's
I'm gonna skip some steps here but I
just wanna this is basically I'm telling
you now something I will tell you
exactly again when we talk about general
relativity but this is the kind of thing
that hearing more than once doesn't hurt
so the Riemann tensor becomes something
which is a collection of numbers which
we might write are lambda Rho mu okay
what this means is a four by four by
four by four set of numbers and those
numbers are exactly the components are
that what you use to convert the
components of V 1 V 2 V 3 into the
components of V 4 so in this case I'll
give you this a little bit more of
details more than you need but hopefully
won't actually cause you active harm
okay so if you let V 1 have components V
1 mu so that's V the component of V 1 in
the time direction in the space
Direction X Direction y direction Z
direction so that's V 1 0 let me call it
V 1 T for time V 1 X V 1 Y v 1z right
for components of a four dimensional
vector in space-time
likewise V 2 is V 2 mu and V 3 becomes V
3 mu then the answer to this question
the original Riemann tensor quest
what is the mat from p1 p2 p3 to v4 is
the for lambda you can use any Greek
letter I want to be the index it doesn't
matter if it's me or lamdaur a roll I
can use alpha or beta it's just an index
it's just a label v4 equals R lambda Rho
mu nu the 3 Rho the 1 mu V 2 nu and just
to be clear what this notation is saying
what I'm doing is I am summing over the
values of Rho mu and nu okay so what
this is saying is I have the vectors I
express the vectors in terms of
coordinates I have a bunch of numbers
giving me characterizing the Riemann
tensor four by four by four by four
array of numbers okay and so I take the
components of V 3 I take the you know
Rho equals messing up my plot here I
take Rho equals 0 and I take Rho equals
0 there and I multiply those things
together and I add that to the thing I
get when Rho equals 1 and when Rho
equals 1 and when Rho equals 2 and Rho
equals 2 and Rho equals 3 and Rho equals
3 I do the same thing from U and V 1 and
nu and V 2 ok and what I will get is
indexed by lambda which is not summed
over on the right hand side you'll
notice then it leaves me with the
components of V 4 so this is an explicit
map from the components of three vectors
to the components of the fourth vector
okay and immediately from this you
notice some things if this is something
that was follow a ball here is a fun
fact you can derive that there is a
symmetry in this case an anti symmetry
of the Riemann tensor are lambda Rho mu
nu again a collection of numbers four
times four times four times four equals
128 different numbers they're related to
each other though in different ways so
for example our lambda Rho mu nu equals
our lambda Rho nu mu minus there's a
relative minus sign between these two
things why is that true
because remember what it meant was this
is V 1 this is V 2 we were going around
a circle in that direction
so basically switching mu and nu
switches the roles of V 1 and V 2 right
because that mu is multiplying V 1 nu is
multiplying V 2 so switching let me put
this over here actually this will be
more useful if the first set of
components of the Riemann tensor
corresponds to going around clockwise in
the loop the second set of components
were reversed nu and mu corresponds to
going around counterclockwise which is
essentially the same information but in
the opposite sense so it always picks up
a minus sign so this is a symmetry or in
this case an anti symmetry of the
Riemann tensor anyway the point is since
there was a question about this but I've
used it to babble on a little bit the
conventional way of storing the
information in a tensor in general
relativity even though the definition of
a tensor is this abstract map thing
between vectors the literal way that you
store it is in a set of numbers a set of
functions over all of space-time ok so
this 4 by 4 by 4 by 4 set of numbers is
like a 4 by 4 matrix a 4 by 4 array in
which every element of the matrix is a 4
by 4 matrix is not a number all right
that's why
yeah that's why general relativity
becomes complicated that's why life is
complicated sometimes all right maybe
that was interesting I don't know I find
it fun I mean you might look you the
point is I am NOT giving you enough
information to do these calculations
I've not given you the explicit formula
for the Riemann tensor in terms of the
metric for example but you get the
spirit of it you get what this you know
that formula for the Riemann tensor you
could look up and it wouldn't be that
hard for you to understand and that is
what professionals in general ativy D
are using you're not that far away from
what the real researchers at the
forefront of their field are doing they
have a lot more background knowledge and
a lot more practice pushing around the
technical symbols but these are the
concepts that they are putting to use ok
let's completely change gear here's
let's let's move to topology a little
bit and talk a little bit more about
home atop II remember home atop II was a
set of concepts classes technically
speaking equivalence classes that looks
like nasus doesn't it
equivalence classes means you know we're
gonna call two things equivalent if and
then you explain what the relationship
is these are classes of maps from
spheres into some space X and we call
that the enth home atop a group of the
space X so he said for example PI one of
the circle well is the set of all the
different ways you can map a circle into
a circle and basically you can either
map it all into the same place or you
can wind around once or you can ride
around twice or you can wind around
minus one times etc so this turns out to
be the integers is classified by a
winding number the integers and indeed
it's not that hard to show you can go on
in your life grow up do more home attabi
theory and show that PI n of s n is
always Z if you map a sphere any number
of dimensions into another sphere of the
same number of dimensions you will
always get the integers there always be
a winding number so people are asking
well okay what if I map spheres into
spheres of different numbers of
dimensions so let's say map let's say I
want to calculate pi one of s 2 what is
that so I have a sphere I'm not gonna
try to make it pretty anymore okay
here's an S 2 and I want to map oops
that's not what I want to do I'm gonna
map a circle into that sphere okay so
here's a circle that's one I want to map
it in well what can I do and I want to
fix a base point so let's fix a base
point here let's say and let me just
draw a particular circle let's say that
I try to get one that wraps around okay
they're wrapped once around but the
point is these are equivalence classes
under smooth deformations so I'm allowed
to what what I'm asking here is can I
deform this particular map
into one let's take a different mat one
that just sort of goes round in a little
circle but does not representing well
the answer is that these are exactly
topologically equivalent I can take this
yellow one and deform it by just moving
upwards in every direction to something
looks like this and then to something
that just wraps oops that was not a very
good illustration of what I'm trying to
do here what I'm trying to say is I can
I can pull this up so let me say that
this goes up to something looks like
that and then I can keep pulling it up
something looks like that I can just
pull it over until it just squeezes down
to a point so the point is that there
are no non-trivial Maps from a circle
into a sphere there's no non-trivial non
contractible way of mapping a single
circle into a two-dimensional sphere so
PI 1 of s 2 equals oops equals 0 equals
the trivial group the group with just
one element okay so there you go and it
turns out that is hard to calculate the
homotopic groups of different spheres it
you know the end spheres mapping into n
spheres is easy but n seers mapping into
Emma spheres is in general very hard
happily what you might guess is that if
you have PI n of SM for n less than M so
if the sphere you're mapping in is
smaller in dimension than the sphere
you're mapping it to then it's always 0
then you can always contract down to a
point okay that's it that's a fun fact
but when n is greater than M it becomes
messy it becomes a weird complicated
thing so I'm not gonna tell you that I
was letting you know that is a weird
complicated thing one thing that that
came across several times I was a little
surprised because I never ever even
thought of it but I think I've realized
ex post facto why it was a thing was the
invertibility of the maps that we talked
about
so consider PI one of our to minus a
point that was an example that we did in
some detail so
have our - and we have a point here that
we remove okay so that's not there
that's not part of the plane anymore in
such a point I've drawn it as a little
disc which is at the point and we're
mapping a sphere with a base point a
circle with the base point into there
and what I drew was things that look
like this you know here's my base point
and I wrap around once okay that's one
thing I can do and there's a
directionality to it like that I can
also reprimand minus one times etc so
there's a winding number supply one of
our to minus a point is also Z just like
for the circle and people said well wait
what about that point right there that's
a point where your circle intersects
itself when it is mapping into this
thing and that means it's not invertible
that means if I give you the point in r2
that I've mapped to I do not uniquely
know which point in the circle I'd map
from this is not an invertible map and
so my answer that is that's fine who
cares there's absolutely no reason why
the maps from the circle to the space
we're asking about the home toppy groups
of should be invertible invertibility
was never mentioned except that i
remembered of course that invertibility
was mentioned when i talk about the
definition of what topology is topology
is the study of homeomorphisms that is
to say maps between spaces that are
invertible that are that are one-to-one
and invertible Maps smooth maps with a
smooth inverse or continuous yeah just
continuous maps with the continuous
inverse okay that's what a homeomorphism
is but this isn't invertible right so
that's true but that's not the thing
we're talking about so the the thing
with the homeomorphism that we're
talking about is between different ways
of let's see think about that light
colored circle that maps around twice
let me remove that a little arrow there
make my life easier here's another
circle and ask to dim sorry
let's get something else here's another
circle that maps around twice let me get
rid of the yellow one also oh yeah look
at that I'm getting good okay so not
getting great but getting good
here is another circle the reps round
twice okay
the homeomorphism of talking about is
between these two circles
okay the orange circle and the green
circle here I want to know whether they
can be smoothly deformed into each other
I mean at least that's one question I
want to know what I really want to know
is what are the spaces that are two - a
point can be smoothly deformed into
that's what would actually be
topologically equivalent what I'm doing
when I'm mapping the circle into a space
or a two sphere into spaces when
calculating homotopic groups of any
different numbers of dimensions I'm
figuring out features of the space that
are invariant under homomorphisms from
the space to itself okay so I'm trying
to figure out features of the space that
don't change when we deform it so r2
minus a minus a point
turns out consider the annulus so the
annulus is I have a region of space in
between two circles okay so this let's
see if I can do this yeah so this region
of space right here is the annulus it
does not include the inner circle or the
outer circle it's just the space in
between that annulus is topologically
equivalent to or to minus a point and
what that means is there is no no test
of topology that you can do to r2 - a
point that gets you a different answer
than gets you at the annulus you can see
that if i for instance mapped circles
into the annulus if i calculated PI one
with some base point I would be able to
go around the hole in it just like I did
with with the
etc if I calculate the dimensionality
the annulus is two-dimensional just like
our to minus a point is and there is
nothing else that would be different
okay sadly topologists are nowhere close
to nor they imagined they ever will
succeed in getting a complete set of
characteristics for topological spaces
that tell you whether or not they are
equivalent but we know that if there are
two topological invariants of a space
that differ between two different spaces
then those topological then those two
spaces are not homomorphic are not
topologically equivalent so we know that
the annulus on the basis of homotopy
it could be equivalent to r2 minus a
point in fact we know it is in this case
but we know it cannot be topologically
equivalent to a sphere because the
sphere has trivial pi-1 and the annulus
has non-trivial by one boom since those
are different we know that they can't be
the same so that's a long-winded way
once again of saying there's nothing
whatsoever wrong or weird about the fact
that my maps of circles into the spaces
I'm looking at cross themselves that
they're not invertible that's just not
something that we really needed to ever
care about okay two more quick things I
really should be quicker than I'm being
but these are irresistible topics I
mentioned topological defects and I
didn't say much about them and it occurs
to me that I'm probably not gonna get a
chance to say much about them for any of
these lectures any of these videos so
why don't I say something a little bit
about them right now so I said that you
know PI 1 is relevant for cosmic strings
PI 0 is relevant for what we call domain
walls PI 2 for mana poles I also
mentioned textures but these are the big
three
okay what I didn't tell you is PI 0 PI 1
or 2 of what so it's not of space space
could be you know just R 3 it could just
be 3 dimensional Euclidean space even if
it's geometry is different its topology
could just be R 3 so R 3 has just one
component so PI 1 of it is just trivial
it's simply connected which is a fancy
way of saying PI one of it is also zero
so PI zero of it is zero PI one of it is
also zero you can track every loop and
you can contract every two sphere also
so it stopwatch weet reveal in all of
those ways but you could get domain
walls strings or mana poles in
three-dimensional space so what's going
on what's going on is it is sup there's
something called let X be the vacuum
manifold of a theory what this means is
we imagine we have some field theory
which let's say some scalar fields like
forget about complicated things just
imagine a simple scalar field in fact
let's imagine one scalar field Phi okay
just a real valued scalar field and has
a potential via Phi and we've looked at
potentials that look like you know Phi
squared simple harmonic oscillator but
let's look a little bit different let's
imagine that V of Phi is minus M Squared
oops minus M Squared Phi squared plus
lambda phi to the fourth these are the
conventional symbols that are used okay
so what does that mean
near zero the thing that's gonna be
important is M squared Phi squared so
this is V of Phi that means that near
Phi equals zero it's gonna be an
upside-down parabola going like that but
as Phi gets bigger and bigger the Lambda
Phi to the fourth will be more and more
important so it's gonna turn over again
and what you're gonna get is something
that looks like this okay let's see if
we can actually pretty that up a little
bit there no clearly we cannot prettied
up effectively so nothing not gonna
worry about that the point is that there
is a minimum value for Phi which is
either here or here there are two
different minimum values so if this is
the whole theory you know you have fine
you have this potential in the early
universe where the temperature is high
Phi is bouncing around because the field
is being buffeted by all these other
fields that what it means to have a high
temperature and everything and the
average value of Phi early on at high
temperature
equals zero this is fancy notation for
average value expectation value of five
but later it's going to be either if we
call this plus little V or - that'll be
again this is the conventional notation
either plus V or minus V so what's gonna
happen is the field will start bouncing
around near the middle and then it will
fall into one minimum or the other and
the vacuum manifold of the theory is the
set of all points for which the energy
is minimized in this case it's two
points okay
Phi equals plus V or Phi equals minus V
and what happens is again at early times
it's near zero it's gonna fall down as
the universe cools into plus V or minus
V but in different regions of space
space once again it could fall down
differently so there could be a region
where v becomes plus V okay but then
around it there's a region where Phi
equals loops minus V very not very good
handwriting there we go
so maybe in one place it fell down in
one direction one place fell down the
other direction the falling down happens
rapidly and there's the speed of light
that says you cannot communicate between
different regions that are too far away
so you can't make sure that the field
falls down the same direction everywhere
so in this it's going to necessarily be
the case that there's a boundary between
these two regions and in that boundary
the field is going to have to go from
one vacuum to another and that's gonna
be a domain wall that it that is going
to be a region where there is energy
because the field has to crawl over this
barrier between the two minima and so
whether or not there is a domain wall I
told you depends on PI zero so what it
means is it depends on PI zero of the
vacuum manifold so this statement here
that v late equals plus V or minus V
this set of possibilities either plus V
or minus V this is the vacuum manifold
this is the space of possible values of
the field with minimum energy it's just
two points in this case okay but PI zero
is the map of just two points into the
space so the map book to just two points
with one fixed into a set of two points
is just two points it's just two
elements PI 0 is not even a group in
general it's just the set of
disconnected components which in this
case is non trivial there's two
disconnected components so PI 0 the
vacuum manifold not being 0 is what
tells you there can be domain walls in
this theory there's no cosmic strings or
anything like that there's just two
points for the vacuum manifold but let's
imagine now you have two scalar fields
call them imaginatively phi1 and phi2
okay and let's imagine our potential V
of Phi 1 and Phi 2 is minus M Squared
Phi 1 squared plus Phi 2 squared so the
generalization of what we had before
plus lambda phi 1 to the fourth plus Phi
2 to the fourth ok another
generalization of what we had before so
the potential V of I'm not going to draw
if I want to Phi 2 but it's going to
look like this there is going to be a
set of points near the bottom where the
potential is minimized or Kenny so this
is V this is Phi 1 this is Phi 2 so this
is called a Mexican hat potential I
don't know why it's not called a
sombrero potential but physicists call
this a Mexican hat potential so the
vacuum manifold the set of points which
the energy is minimized is that circle
the vacuum and a fold of this theory is
s1 topologically s1 so PI 1 the
fundamental group of the vacuum manifold
of this theory is
zero is Z does the integers it has a
winding number and what that means is
there can be a cosmic string so if again
I draw a space your space okay imagine
that I parameterize where I am in the
vacuum manifold just as I was making
coordinates on a circle before so let me
put an angle thought and I can call Phi
Theta call it theta no matter what so
theta goes around the circle okay so I
can have at every point in space the
field once in early times it's at zero
and it's gonna fall down randomly along
the circle so I can parameterize that by
drawing little arrows right to say you
know I fall down there or there or there
or whatever and as a matter of topology
it can happen that these arrows
describing where I am in the vacuum
manifold fall down in a configuration
that looks like that and if I ask how I
can smoothly they'd fill that in in
between yeah there's no problem smoothly
filling it in all the way around all
throughout space I can fill it in some
smooth way until I get very close to the
middle and there has to be a singularity
there has to be a point where I climb
out of the vacuum manifold and sit back
at the top at 5 i1 equals Phi 2 equals
zero in that space that place will have
energy because it's at the top of the
potential and that will be the location
of a cosmic string you might say it
doesn't look like a string to me looks
like a point but I've only drawn three
dimensions of space so if I draw you
know the third dimension Z oops so if I
can I deform this I wonder if I can
probably not but if I say there's a
third dimension pointing this way Z then
this point that is the cosmic string is
going to extend in that Z direction okay
there's a one-dimensional line through
space where the field lives here at the
top of its potential and there's energy
there and that's a cosmic string and
that is because
hi one of vacuum Ana fold is the
integers so in fact there will be cosmic
strings with winding number 2 etc so
that's where the relationship comes from
between topology and topological defects
it's not the topology of space that
we're talking about it's the topology of
the space of zero energy field
configurations that we're talking about
that's what the vacuum manifold is ok
one final topic and honestly I really
shouldn't do this but I'm gonna try to
do it very very briefly and I shouldn't
do it because it's actually kind of
subtle it involves calculus an important
way but it was asked so I should answer
and it is the topic of co homology not
cosmology this is a completely different
thing so there is homology and Co
homology which are two different sets of
topological invariants over and above
the Homa toffee that we already talked
about so home atop e is one thing
homology is another thing Co homology is
another thing and they're all very
difficult in fact physicists and
mathematicians have different attitudes
towards these because physicists really
like home atop e groups because they
keep appearing in situations like this
cosmic strings are classified by
homotopic groups but to calculate
homotopic oops I mean PI 1 of s 1 is is
easy but PI 37 of some complicated
symmetry group of something might be
really really hard to calculate or some
other manifold might be very hard to
calculate whereas these topological
invariants Co homology and it's it's
friend it's dual space homology are easy
to calculate relatively speaking but
hard to actually put into practice hard
to care about in some way so
mathematicians like them so they can
calculate them so what is Co homology
all about comb ology is basically here's
the example you should keep in mind
think about a function and its
derivative ok think about the simplest
function there is think about here's X
here's f of x equals x
okay so I can have that function f of X
equals x I mean I should have tried to
draw it through the center there yeah I
can draw it through central better I
think there we go f of x equals x and I
could have its derivative write DF DX
just equals one and both of those things
exist
there's no complication and saying what
the derivative is once you have the
function and you can go back and forth
right you can say x equals the integral
of DF DX times DX in fact this is called
the fundamental theorem of calculus that
you can go back and forth like this so
that's nice and kind of obvious and no
big deal why are you bothering it what
does have to do with topology okay well
your life is a little bit calculus well
I'm a little bit more complicated if you
live on a topologically non-trivial
space this space on which the function
was defined X is just the real line
there's no nothing topologically that
complicated about it what if we would do
this on a circle rather than on the line
so on a circle let's think of a circle
as theta but theta just goes from zero
to 2pi and then if you go from zero to
2pi you wrap around so I'm not going to
draw the wrapping around but you can
imagine it in your mind okay so you can
plot f of theta equals theta you can try
to plot it for what you find is that is
not a well-defined function right the
let me up here
let you do the following thing let me
convert my derivatives in two colors and
then I will plot them so let me make
this the color green DF DX equals a
number one and I'm going to integrate DF
DX I can plot DF DX it equals one it's
the derivative of x itself okay now this
is not a well-defined function f of
theta equals theta
as different values for theta equal zero
and 2pi but the whole point of the
circle is riposte identify zero with 2pi
so in between zero and 2pi it's
perfectly well defined but if we're
sticklers which mathematicians like to
be and this is just not defined over the
whole circle but we can forget that for
the moment and we can calculate its
derivative what is the derivative of x
with respect to theta well that's one
just like it used to be writing just
like it was in the X example so we can
plot the derivative of f DF D theta
equals one and that is well defined
everywhere on the circle right because
DF D theta equals one at both they'd
equal zero and theta equals 2pi so
somehow we can imagine so if you if you
started with the function that was just
equal to one okay and said well I wanted
to find a function X which is the
integral of that function so in other
words I imagine that that function was a
DF D theta
oops I said X but I meant beta sorry so
if I said I wanted to find the integral
just like the fundamental theorem of
calculus lets me do then something goes
wrong so in other words there are
functions which I cannot integrate to
get another function you know the
function that is just one if I integrate
it it's gonna be this theta function but
that's not well defined so the
fundamental theorem of calculus is
failing us in some way and the reason
why it's failing us is ultimately
because of the topology of the circle
okay so in other words what we're saying
here is you can ask the question how
many functions are there that are or are
not integrals of other functions right
how many functions are there whose
integral is well defined is another way
of saying it and I'm not gonna go into
the details but that's what Co homology
does Co homology basically says if you
have something that looks like a
derivative can it be globally integrated
to get you another function or not and
it turns out of course you know that's a
very simple thing but guess what there's
the second derivative and the
derivative and so forth and you can do
this in various different ways you can
get spaces of different dimensionalities
and you can talk about the Houma toppy
vex re the the co homology vector space
corresponding to different topological
spaces and it turns out to be much
easier to calculate it's another way in
some sense of finding holes because you
know that we just noticed that the real
line and the circle are different in Co
homology but we already knew that so
it's not a new fact but there's other
spaces for which the ease of calculating
comb ology lets us topologically
distinguish between the spaces in a much
more straightforward way I could do a
much better job of explaining this but
it would take a long time so I just want
to give you a little hint of it because
the reason why it's worth giving you a
little hint is Houma toppy is easy to
visualize once again right you map
circles or spheres into other spaces
then you deform them and you might ask
well is it doesn't shouldn't that
capture everything and the answer is no
it does not capture everything and so
this is yet another kind of tool you can
ask about the equivalence classes of
spaces that can or cannot be integrated
or differentiated in different ways to
form other functions and that gives you
another way of characterizing the
topology of the space so once I give you
two examples on the top E and Co
homology now you can imagine there's an
infinite number of examples right which
is probably not practically true but
certainly there are many many different
ways of calculating of characterizing
the topology of the space and that's
what topologists do for a living so if
you're a young person who wants to
become a topologist you're gonna be
generalizing things like this for the
rest of your life it'll be a lot more
fun but that makes it sound I promise